joe biden finally wanders out to the
microphones and he begins and i have to
say
i was shocked
shocked by his appearance okay the the
lasting images from this presser are not
going to be any of the things he said
it's just going to be the images and
there were two particular ones that came
out one was joe biden like a small child
being called on in class without having
done his homework burying his face
in the podium essentially as peter ducey
asks him a difficult question here's
what that looked like i'm asking you a
question is that accurate the best year
or not
do you think that people have an issue
with
pulling out of that
that image of the old man clutching a
binder to his chest
and lowering his head
as though he is being victimized and put
upon
after 13 american service members die in
service to his garbage mission
that is an unbelievable image